[Music]
hello and welcome to
sophie ridge on sunday british summer
time has
begun the [ __ ] have gone forward never
a nice moment for those of us who have
to get up early on sunday
but on the positive side it means we are
one hour closer to the next step
in the government's road map out of
lockdown and tomorrow is a big day
the stay-at-home rule will be dropped in
england you'll be able to play outdoor
sport
six people will be able to meet outside
temperatures could even reach the
mid-20s this week
so after some pretty bleak months there
are
reasons to be cheerful in just a moment
we'll be talking to the culture
secretary
oliver dowden about that lockdown
roadmap and whether we'll have enough
vaccine supplies to keep up the pace
the shadow home secretary nick thomas
simmons will be responding for labour
it's been a monumental week in scottish
politics as alex salmond launched a new
party just six weeks before the
elections
we'll be speaking to the most senior mp
to have defected from the snp
kenny mccaskill it also poses no
questions for scotland's pro-union
parties too so we're going to be talking
to
the scottish conservatives leader
douglas ross
nostra ghani one of the mps sanctioned
by the chinese government for speaking
up about human rights abuses
will also be on the show and this week
we've been investigating how the
pandemic has affected young people
exploited by gangs first though we can
speak to the government's culture
secretary oliver
dowden who joins us now and good morning
mr dowden
does feel like there are some reasons to
be cheerful tomorrow we're going to see
six people being able to meet outside in
england
and also outdoor sport restarting what's
the first thing you're going to be doing
with your newfound freedoms
well actually with my newfound freedoms
first thing i'll be doing is going up to
warrington to see some rugby league some
grassroots sports happening that's
one of the things that we promise we do
we get grassroots sports back
up and running first and we've done that
first after schools and i think tomorrow
is an important day
we're making progress with the roll out
of the vaccine
we're making progress through the road
map which means that we can take some
important steps tomorrow
first of all allowing grass sports to
resume which is so important for our
nation's physical and mental health but
also
ensuring that people can once again meet
their loved ones
outside of course it's important that we
continue to
abide by the rules but this is an
important step back towards normality
and it's a step that we're able to take
because of course the vaccine rollout
has been
going well so far there has been some
concern about bumpiness
over the next month or so but the mail
on sunday were
reporting today that the modern vaccine
could be rolled out to under 50s in
about three weeks time
is that timetable broadly right when
should we expect to see moderna hitting
the uk at the uk well we're still on
track with our timetable so if you
remember we delivered for the most
vulnerable people by mid-february
we're confident that we'll deliver for
all over 50s
by the middle of april and also to the
most
vulnerable remaining most vulnerable and
then by the end of july
we'll have vaccinated first dose but
when do we when should we expect
modernist specifically
well we don't get into the details of
supply chains but the health secretary
has indicated that he would expect later
this month we'd start to see moderna
okay and now the sunday times is also
reporting the uk is planning to offer
3.7 million vaccine doses to ireland
is that true is that true well clearly
our first priority is ensuring that we
deliver vaccines
in the united kingdom we clearly don't
currently have a surplus of vaccines
should we get to the point where we have
a surplus of vaccines we'd make
decisions on the allocation of that
surplus
um so sorry and so we've also obviously
seen vaccine roll out issues with the eu
there's been a threat to block
exports of astrazeneca to the uk as well
deal is said to be close on that what is
actually happening
well we continue to have constructive
discussions with the eu
our position is is very clear that the
eu should not be engaging in
blocking exports and that they should
honour the pledge
that ursula von de line gave to prime
minister boris johnson
a short while ago whereby they agreed
that any contracts should be honored so
that is to say that
if vaccines have been provided in
honoring of the contract
that that should be honored by the eu
and we expect them to abide by that
okay it does feel a little bit like
we're not getting much clarity this
morning
uh on the vaccine supply issues on the
vaccine roll out and
you're not telling us what the latest is
on moderna despite the fact that we've
been told that we've got this
new vaccine supply wall going on you're
critical of the
eu of course what is the situation when
are we going to be getting the next
supply of vaccines such as modena in the
uk people are really worried they want
to know
yes i understand people want to know and
we are very clear to people we will
deliver on the promises
that we made so the promise we made was
that by the middle
of april the middle of this month the
first dose of the vaccine would be
available
to all over 50s and the remaining most
vulnerable and we said
that by the end of july all adults would
get access to the first vaccine
alongside that
we'd fill in the second doses within 12
weeks as promised
i can assure anyone watching this
program that we remain on course to do
that
because we're on course to do that that
means we're still on course with the
roadmap
which means that we are taking another
important step from tomorrow
towards back doing the things that we
love and this is the approach the
government's been taking
sticking to the roll out of the vaccine
and sticking to this cautious
but hopefully irreversible road map
that's the importance assurance that
people should take and it's only because
we've managed to stick to that path that
we can take those steps tomorrow
so i just don't understand why you won't
be more open about what's happening we
just expected to take it on trust that
all of these things will happen
on the dates you say why won't you just
tell us when we can expect moderna it's
quite simple question
well first of all i wouldn't say you
have to take us on trust i would say
take us
on our record we said that uh the most
vulnerable groups of people would get
their vaccine by the middle of february
they got it by the middle of february we
said that over 50s
and the most vulnerable will get it by
the middle april we'll deliver on that
we've also always said there'll be ups
and downs in the the vaccine we're not
going to give a running commentary on
the supply i have also
indicated as a health secretary has said
that we do expect moderna to come later
this month people should take the
reassurance
that we have delivered what we promised
so far and that we will continue to do
so
and as a consequence of that we are able
to take these cautious steps from
tomorrow
in removing some of the the most
restrictions
in relation to covert okay the french
foreign minister said that the uk will
struggle with supplies for second doses
but brussels won't be blackmailed
in his words into exporting doses to try
and solve the problem can you guarantee
that everyone will get their second dose
within that 12-week period
yes of course we have been planning that
all the way through so it's one of the
most important considerations
uh as we've rolled out the vaccine not
only do we stick to our
pledges in relation to the first vaccine
we must ensure that people get their
second vaccine so in all of our planning
we have factored in getting that that
second dose of the vaccine and indeed
that is
one of the most important thing for the
most elderly and vulnerable that they
get the added protection from that
second dose
okay now of course given the fact that
different countries are very different
stages
of the vaccine roll out um one thing
that a lot of people are worried about
are what's going to be happening with
holidays what's going to happen with
summer holidays
is it true the government's considering
like a traffic like system to deal with
that where for example
if an amber option would allow you to
have a shorter quarantine period but
with increased testing
well we're exploring all these issues as
part
of the international travel task force
that will be reporting at the beginning
of next month grant chapter transport
secretary is leading on that
so that we will set out to the next
steps as part of that process
so you are considering it then
we consider all options as as part of
the
uh the the travel uh task force i think
you would expect that
when government formulates policy the
way we do this is we look at all the
different options
we weigh them up we come to a position
and then when we've come to that
position
we publish that position and that's the
the position that we'll be setting out
at the beginning of
of next month clearly there are
challenges around international travel
you only have to look across the
continent and see the the rising case
rates
in many of our nearest neighbors it has
been in the past the case
that those rising infection rates have
seen their way through to the
the uk we're hopeful that that won't
happen
this time around because of our progress
with the vaccine and so on but we do
need to be cautious about that that is
that is why we are just
we've we've got this review we're
looking at it carefully and you'll get
the results of that at the beginning of
next month
okay uh considering all options we look
forward to a bit more detail
on that let's see if i can get a bit
more detail on something else and you've
said you've been looking at vaccine
passports as a way of
allowing people to go back to for
example live sporting events and
is that likely to happen and how is it
going to work
well this is an important uh
consideration one of a range of
different mitigations that we are
using to probe to look at looking at as
we progress through the the roadmap so
if you remember sophie
uh we've made the commitment that all
being well stage three by the 15th
of may we'll get back to essentially the
position we were
last summer so for example you'll be
able to have social distancing
indoors and outdoors but that means that
many areas of our national life for
example
theatres or large sporting events still
don't remain viable
and it's really essential that we get to
the point whereby those things can
operate viably commercially and that
means
some further easing of restrictions
that's why we've said by stage four
we'll look to remove
as many of those restrictions as we
possibly can now we're conducting a
range of pilots
as to how we can achieve that and we're
looking at all sorts of factors
so for example ventilation we're looking
at behavior
we're looking at the spread risk so
we're testing before and after
but it's also important that as part of
that we consider the role that covets
certification
might play now that work is being led by
my colleague the chancellor of the duchy
of lancaster
and it's an important factor that we
need to consider as part of this
okay um as you said it's been an
incredibly
difficult time for a lot of the
industries that your brief touches on
whether it's sport whether it's
culture whether it's hospitality of
course very linked
to some of those big venues as well
now your department's been given almost
2 billion pounds to support the culture
sector
has all that money being given out now
well remember the uh the first
allocation was one and a half billion
pounds so that's for this financial year
we've already announced a billion pounds
worth of that helping over 4 000
organizations
up and down the country so for example
i'll be going up to
wolverhampton tomorrow to see the the
theater there another beneficiary of
that
and at the end of this week we'll
announce the remaining allocations to
take us up to the one and a half
billion pounds that will see those
organizations through to the end of
june then the chancellor announced that
the budget a further allocation of 300
million pounds
the focus of that really is about
helping those organizations
reopen and restart as we progress along
the roadmap and we'll be
opening applications for that final
phase very shortly
i'm struggling to see why it's taken so
long to get the money
to where it's really needed because the
1.57 million
was announced last 1.57 billion sorry
lance announced last july you say a
billion of that has been given out
national order offers found only 4.95
million paid out by february
of this year when you know we've seen
reports of
theaters closing of you know football
clubs on their knees
of live music venues shutting down
forever why is it taking so long to
actually get some of this money out
well so there's a range of different
points you you raised there first of all
clearly things have moved on since the
national audit office report in february
we did make a conscious choice though
it's just to come in
like just to come in there because i i
accept your point that things have moved
on since february but this money was
was announced in july so it's been
pretty slow
sorry i was trying to i was trying to
answer the the second point which is
that we did make a conscious choice in
relation to the remaining 400 million
we held that back because we wanted to
see how we progressed
through this year and from the
conversations we had with theaters and
other organizations
they wanted us to have that flexibility
we'll be announcing the allocation of
that
that further amount of money we've
rolled forward the time they can use
that until the end of june
and then clearly we haven't been able to
allocate the the the extra 300
million the chancellor just announced
that in the budget and that was always
intended for the
the next financial year and to help that
recovery
process you also mentioned sport uh just
today we've announced
uh most of the remainder of the sports
winter survival package
and again we'll be moving on to the
summer survival package
that will apply from the beginning of
the new financial year and in relation
to all of those in relation to theaters
our sporting institutions up and down
the country
i remember when this crisis first hit i
was being warned
that we could lose vast swathes of our
culture and sporting life
it is only thanks to those interventions
that we have made
that we've been able to protect them and
the vast majority of our theaters the
vast majority of our sports clubs
have been protected thanks to that in
those interventions that sit alongside
things like the furlough scheme and
others that have helped our national
life
survive the terrible impacts of the
covert restrictions
while we're on sports and culture what's
the latest on whether the euros could be
held in england
well we are committed to holding the
euros and uh we fully expect that those
the euros
will happen so yes they are they are
going ahead as planned the the big
moments of the euros are going to happen
in the uk so that's to say the
semi-finals
and the finals so with some group
matches as well it's always been the
case that other matches will take place
across europe and we expect that to
remain the case okay that makes sense
and
sticking on football and the england
captain harry kane
has said that the squad needs to have a
real think about whether or not to join
other
national teams who are protesting about
human rights abuses in
qatar who of course are going to be at
the venue for the world cup in 2022.
do you think the uk and the england
football team need to be a bit stronger
in calling out qatar's record on human
rights
well we as a government never hesitate
in calling out human rights
abuses where wherever they happen in
terms of the actions that england
football players take i've always said
it's
it's up to them it's not for me as
culture secretary to be prescribing what
they they should and shouldn't do they
they'll they'll act appropriately uh and
they'll make decisions between
themselves
so it's up to football as not government
ministers then
so so for government ministers we have
been absolutely clear in terms of
calling out human rights abuses in terms
of
actions that footballers themselves take
that's clearly up to them
um david cameron is being investigated
by a lobbying watchdog the one he set up
actually over his work for
greensell finance group since leaving
number 10.
now this was originally reported by the
financial times him contacting rishi
sunex private phone to try and get
access
for that company to a loan scheme set up
by the government now the sunday times
details this morning how
lex greensville who set up this company
was given some pretty extraordinary
access to government
when david cameron was prime minister at
the time you were david cameron's
deputy chief of staff did you ever met
meet lex greensell did you raise any
concerns about the access that he was
given
well i've been racking my brains i took
to the very best of my recollection
i never met with them but i can't say
for for sure i'd have to
to to check over the the records but i
have zero recollection i'm pretty sure
that i
i didn't meet with them but i think you
you raised investigation i believe that
david cameron has been uh cleared as a
result of that
and uh any appropriate meetings will of
course be properly
declared and i don't there was any
change in in government policy and
certainly from working with david
cameron
over a number of years i always found
him a man of the utmost integrity and
i've no doubt that that would pertain in
this situation as well
quite a lot of the allegations in the
sunday times this morning
are talking about how lex greenzer was
given access through jeremy hayward of
course
head of the civil service at that point
is that something that
should raise any concerns or do you
think it merits further investigation
no i think all of these things will have
been properly declared i remember when i
worked in downing street we had very
tight restrictions about the
declarations of
meetings those would be fully in the the
public domain
uh clearly and sadly jeremy hayward is
no longer
with us but again he was somebody that
always uh abided punctiliously with the
the rules uh in relation to engaging
with with third parties
okay and just finally there's been an
outpouring of allegations about
harassment
assault abuse against uh some of
britain's leading private schools
what's happening is there an
investigation that's taking place and
how important
is it that the government prioritizes
this
well these are very serious allegations
and clearly
any child at school or indeed anyone
needs to
feel safe and if there are concerns that
people have they must raise them with
responsible adults or with the police
in terms of the the actual steps being
taken the is the independent schools
uh investigation uh an inspection regime
and the the dfe can call them in and
we'll
will deal with that uh as appropriate so
either take measures
uh to deal with those safeguarding
issues or ultimately to to close the
school so we have those in
independent inspection regimes and it's
important those uh
are undertaken as appropriate okay
oliver dowd and thank you very much for
being on the show this morning oliver
dowd on there
now there's been no shortage of big
moments in scottish politics in the last
few months but the announcement of a new
political party by alex salmond this
week
was still a huge development the
electoral system in scotland means that
the pro-independence alba party
might not damage the snp on paper but of
course the independence movement
appears as divided as ever now this
weekend nicola sturgeon has said there
are serious questions
about alex salmon's behavior towards
women in the past
which she says raises real questions
about the appropriateness of any return
to public office
well yesterday the former justice
secretary uh kenny mccaskill became the
most senior person yet
to quit the snp to join alba he joins us
now thank you very much for being
with us mr mccaskill now you of course
support scottish independence
but then six weeks before these critical
scottish elections you quit the snp
why do you think the snp is no longer
the party to deliver independence
well this is about adding to the snp
this is about delivering the independent
super majority
we are not contesting the lists of the
constituency seats that will be for
individuals to decide and certainly i'll
be voting snp
uh where i live but we're contesting the
list seat and in 2016 over a million
people voted
snp on the list and only four list msps
were returned for the snp
an opinion poll just yesterday indicated
that none would be returned
so what we are doing by asking people to
vote alba on the list
is to deliver that independent super
majority so that on the 6th of may
when it's our election is counted the
scottish parliament
will stand against boris johnson it will
be scottish democracy having supported
independence
overwhelmingly i hope that will be
juxtaposed with boris johnson
saying that scotland's just got to do
what he says and that's unacceptable
come on this isn't about boris johnson
is it you might say of course i
understand fully that the list system
means that in many ways
it might appear to benefit the
independence movement on paper but what
you're doing is making this election all
about cat fighting
in the independence movement nicholas
sturgeon versus alex salmond
i think some people might say well hang
on how can you say that you're trying to
help the smp by quitting
no this is about delivering that
independent super majority
i'll be 63 next month sophie throughout
my life
scotland has rejected the tories not
just boris johnson but thatcher heath
and others before
and continually were left with the tory
government we now stand with our economy
threatened by brexit
with our health service threatened by
trade deals upcoming nuclear weapons
escalating that are based on the clyde
that's simply unacceptable
the time has come for scotland to decide
its own destiny
you think the snp alone can't defeat
boris johnson and cannot
uh deliver independence that's that's
this the arithmetic's clear
in 2016 the snp did not get a majority
they had one million list votes and
returned four msps
the independent super majority could be
delivered by the alba party on list the
yes movement the independence movement
is a broad church it encompasses
more than one political party and
encompasses many people
in other or no political parties so we
believe that the time has come for that
independence movement to come together
reflected by more than one political
party but to make sure that there's a
scottish people who prevail and it's the
scottish people who decide
and that will be the scottish parliament
that will then confront boris johnson
after the 6th of may so this is all
about helping the snp
i'm a bit baffled by their reaction to
it all to be honest um after you
defected in blackford said
of you he's been an increasing
embarrassment to many in the snp
and his departure is somewhat of a
relief doesn't sound like you're leaving
the best of terms
well snp speak for themselves i've made
it clear that i'll be supporting a
former colleague in east lothian it's be
up to individuals in alberta to decide
what they do
but the yes movement the independence
movement is a broad church it's not
simply the snp the snp on their own it
failed to achieve a majority in 2016.
alba party can ensure that there is an
independence
majority in 2021 we won't be beholden to
the snp because we are
not the snp but we certainly start
campaigning for independence and we
certainly stand on the radical tradition
and the radical policies
that the snp used to and i believe in
many instances still support
used to stand on it's a bit of a slip of
the tongue there
no well there are issues that i think
have caused many people concerning the
snp
that's why some have come over just
today we had the
uh equalities officer from the snp
coming over
along with a colleague the other party
now has more
mps in scotland than the labour party we
are here to stay
we are going to deliver a result in 2021
in the mention
to make sure that it's the super
majority that is delivered
this election is already becoming about
independence we've got to make sure that
the outcome is about an independent
majority within the scottish parliament
and that allows scotland's democracy to
choose we cannot go on
under boris johnson we've had austerity
inflicted
it's going to increase the time has come
for scotland to go its own way
and to do so would require to be an
independent nation
i'm just trying to work out why you
think alex salmond is the man to help
deliver
the independence that you want because
according to the latest opinion poll for
sky news
nicholas sturgeon's got a plus 21
approval rating among scots
plus 2067 among independent supporters
alex salmon's approval rating is -60
and even 68 of yes supporters have an
unfavorable view of him i mean do you
really think he's an
asset to the independence course well i
think alex almond was pivotal to the
independence cause and delivered the
2014
referendum
and that's why others have come on board
just yesterday we had corey wilson a
former
snp mp joined the party just today we
have councillor lynn anderson
the equalities officer for the snp they
put their trust and faith in mr salmond
and exactly the same as a scottish jury
acquitted him on all charges
a jury that was overwhelmingly
represented by women
uh you say very rightly of course that
he was
acquitted by that jury nicholas scotland
nicholas sturgeon says though in a
scotland on sunday interview today that
serious questions have been raised
about the appropriateness of his
behavior towards women while he held the
highest office in the land
i think that raises real questions about
the appropriateness of any return to
public office
do you think that alex salmon still has
serious questions to answer as nicholas
sturgeon says
no we've had two court cases he has been
successful in both a civil and indeed a
criminal court action
that is behind us we go forward and
indeed it's from this
student to our school but why others in
the snp who behaved inappropriately were
not dealt with
but we're going to keep this positive on
independence
we're not here to battle with the snp we
are here to win
on the list and that will be contesting
against the snp because they can't
deliver
that independence super majority but we
are part of the wider
independence movement it is not the
prerogative of one
political party there is more than one
political party pursuing independence in
scotland
and i will continue to campaign for
independence target my fire against the
unionist parties who are once again
seeking to coalesce
and i would hope that other political
parties would recognize that it's a
common cause of independence
not name throwing that they should be
carrying out now of course
as you say you know alexander's always
denied all of the harassment allegations
made against him
he was cleared of all the charges in
court in portland state
but in the court case his defense lawyer
did say i'm not here to suggest he
always behaved well or he couldn't have
been a better man on occasions
because he certainly could have been
better and alex salmond has previously
said you know i'm no saint
i've got flaws are you comfortable
being in a party with him as leader well
let him without sin cast the first stone
since we're
speaking on a sunday equally you're just
asking a tory minister about behavior
within the tories i think the people i'm
most concerned about
it would be allowing boris johnson to
continue
running the roost in scotland along with
the likes of pretty patel or matt
hancock
so when it comes to this i think the snp
the alba party
and indeed the politicians in scotland
most parties stand far above that
so i'm comfortable and as i say that was
shown by corey wilson and indeed
lynn anderson today showing that they
have every faith in him
but this is about the alba party
delivering
that independence super majority it's
not about any individual
and it's not about name throwing or
tittle title and i hope that people in
my former party will reflect
upon who's actually shown commitment in
the past and who's still showing
commitment in the future
and that we should show some common
cause rather than as i say
seek to divide the independence movement
just finally at the last election you of
course stood
under the snp banner you're now
representing a different party
shouldn't you hold a by-election
no i'll be doing what has been done
before at the outset of the scottish
parliament donald jr and labour mps
exercised the dual mandate
during the parliament that i served in
alex hammond and indeed john swinney the
deputy first minister of the scottish
parliament
uh stood on a dual mandate and i
represented both westminster and
hollywood
so i'll be seeking to represent
hollywood as well as retaining and
continue to serve my constituents in
east lothian
okay thank you very much for being on
the program kenny mccaskill there
thank you
now because the way the scottish
elections work as we were discussing
where voters got two votes it's possible
that alba does more damage to the greens
or even the conservatives and labor than
the snp
now the conservatives are so worried
about this their leader in scotland
douglas ross yesterday called for fellow
unionist parties to put aside their
differences
and form an alliance to stop a second
independence referendum douglas ross
joins us now and
firstly just your reaction to the kenny
mccaskill
interview he says this is all about
helping the snp building a super
majority do you think it will work that
way
well that's what it's all about for the
snp and nationalists
i listened to every word from the album
party representing
kenny mccaskill there and not once did
he mention covered recovery
or rebuilding after this pandemic well i
talked about
well he didn't speak about recovery
after this pandemic and how we get
scotland
back up and running after the last 12
months because for nationalists
it's all about another independence
referendum and that's what i was saying
to
fellow unionist leaders here in scotland
yesterday we can't help the recovery we
can't rebuild scotland
when all the narrative from the scottish
government from the snp
and from the albuquerque it's going to
be focused on another independence
referendum so we've got to work together
to stop them
i'm interested in this you say you want
to work together with other
pro-unionists and
parties you've written to the labour and
the lib dem leaders have they replied
yet
yes i mean sadly they've both turned
down that offer but
the offer remains we've got to look at
how we approach this new threat
as you said in your introduction there
this is
could split the sm people but they don't
get many msps off the regional list so
it's more likely
to do more harm to the unionist party so
we've got to understand that threat
not ignore it and assume that we can
continue as normal
we've got to put our party politics to
one side in this important reference
effective referendum because the
nationalists want this election to be
about another
independence representative to separate
scotland
i'm just trying to work out what this
offer actually means
you know you want to work together with
other pro-unionist parties i mean are
you actually saying that you might go
into government a coalition government
if you like with labor
well that's one of the pledges that we
would sign up to a unionist manifesto if
the numbers work
after the election to work together to
get rid of the nationalists
so you would go into government with
labour i'm saying that's what we need to
get around the table and discuss because
after the last 14 years in scotland
for the snp have been in charge we've
not had the focus
on the economy on protecting jobs on
education and supporting nhs
we've had a focus on independence that's
the snp's priority and the nationalist
priority
so we've got to look at how we can build
up as big a coalition as possible
to stop that and the speed at which the
labour party and the liberal democrats
refused that offer yesterday
tells me that we've got to just unite
behind the strongest opposition to the s
p then that's the scottish conservatives
i'm a bit confused because you say that
the problem with the snp and the album
parties that they want to make this
election all about independent
independence rather than other issues
but surely by talking about and calling
for
a pro-union alliance that is also making
the election all about independence
isn't it
well that's responding to the threat
that has now emerged that the alba party
have set up to work
with the scottish national party to get
super majority for independence
that means there will not be an
opportunity to discuss our recovery
not be an opportunity for the scottish
parliament to be laser focused on
rebuilding
after copenhage because the nationalists
will drag us back to the same old
divisive destructive arguments of the
past
isn't the truth that actually making
this election all about independence
benefits the scottish conservatives
doesn't it you want to position yourself
as the most strongly pro-union party
we are the the strongest pro-union party
in scotland we've shown that
in the last election five years ago we
stopped the acmp getting a majority
the scottish labour party so you want it
to be about independence don't you
no i want it to be about education in
scotland i wanted to be about protecting
jobs in scotland i wanted to be about
our recovery
from this pandemic as you heard from
kenny mccaskill not a single word about
recovery or rebuilding from the alba
party
for nationalists is all about
independence so you and you think you
can
choose achieve all of those domestic
objectives most easily in coalition with
labor
well we've got to work with all parties
who want to stop the nationalists
they've been in power for a decade and a
half and look at what they've done in
scotland
nicholas sturgeon said judge her on her
number one priority
which would be education but of course
everyone can see her number one priority
has always been another independence
referendum and separating scotland from
the rest of the uk
we've got to wake up to this threat we
cannot continue to bury our heads in the
sun like the scottish labour party want
to do
the threat is real it's in front of us
now let's place
that epic and work together to stop the
nationalists otherwise scottish politics
will again be dominated by the
independence debate
if the next scottish parliament contains
the majority even a supermajority for
independence will boris johnson just
refuse to grant a referendum in any
circumstances
well sadly that doesn't even matter to
the nationalists because they said
they'll go ahead with a wild cat illegal
referendum enemy
so no matter what happens if you vote
for a nationalist party
yet nicholas sturgeon's nationalist or
alex almonds nationalists
their priority will be another
referendum whether it's a
legal referendum or an illegal wildcat
referendum they will not be focused on
recovery
they cannot be focused on rebuilding
scotland when they're trying to rip us
out of the united kingdom
the question i asked wasn't about what
the snp will do though it's about what
the conservatives will do since you are
you know the leader of the scottish
conservatives
if there is a majority for independence
in the next scottish parliament
will boris johnson refuse to grant a
referendum
but that's the problem sophie that's
exactly the point i'm making it doesn't
matter
if it will not though other people can
decide whether it matters people want to
know what it's going to do
yeah and the prime minister has been
clear he does not want another
independent referendum in scotland we
are in the middle of a pandemic we need
to focus on our recovery and rebuilding
but the nationals will ignore that the
nationalists have already said and
nicolas sturgeon
set up a commission within the snp with
an 11 point plan to have another
independence referendum
even if it's an illegal wildcat
referendum without a
section 30 order from the uk government
we know that boris johnson doesn't want
another referendum but will he refuse to
grant
another referendum in all circumstances
the prime minister has been clear he's
not going to grant
him the powers for another independence
referendum because he thinks it's
absolutely wrong for scotland right now
to be dragged back into that destructive
arguments of the past
to go through all the pain and suffering
that we have in scotland through that
last debate
we should be focused on recovery and
rebuilding but the nationals are going
to ignore that and they're going to say
we'll have a referendum anyway and that
will take scotland backwards rather than
focusing on our recovery and rebuilding
from this pandemic
would it be democratic though for boris
johnson to refuse to grant a referendum
if there
is a majority in favour of independence
parties
well it wouldn't be democratic for the
nationals to go ahead with a wildcat
legal referendum but they're going to do
it anyway
and this is the whole point this is why
i'm asking people to unite behind the
strongest party
to stop the snp and to stop the
nationalists i'd like to do it with the
scottish labour party and the local
democrats but if they're not up for that
fight if they can't see the threat in
front of us right now
then people have to see there is a party
that's willing to challenge the smp
willing to stand up to the nationalist
threat that we are facing here in
scotland and that's the scottish
conservatives we stopped from five years
ago
we can do it again but the threat is
very real it's in front of us now we've
got a short time to stop them
and everyone has to back the strongest
party to stop the nationalists and
that's the scottish conservatives
okay thank you very much for being on
the program douglas ross there thank you
now that of course was the leader of the
scottish conservatives over the next few
weeks
we're going to be speaking to the other
major parties in scotland in the run-up
to those crucial
elections on the 6th of may now covid
has changed so many things including
unfortunately how many
gangs operate and exploit young people
as a result of the pandemic gangs are
increasingly using social media to groom
children a new report out today
shared exclusively with the show
suggests the typical profile of a victim
is changing
we've been investigating that this week
the picturesque market town of stafford
is not the place you would associate
with gang activity
but thanks to covert vulnerable young
people in quiet corners like this
are falling into the hands of the county
line's drug trade
during lockdown i didn't want to be at
home i was always arguing and fighting
with my parents
i went out all the time to avoid them i
was bored
and lonely we can't tell you alicia's
real name as it would put her at risk
and her words have been revoiced but
she's just 14 years old and struggled
with her mental health during lockdown
when an 18 year old boy messaged her on
snapchat she thought it could be the
start of an exciting new relationship
i met him on snapchat he added me and we
just started talking
he persuaded me to meet him so i did and
he seemed really nice
but things quickly changed alicia was in
the clutches of a county lines gang
forced to run drugs carry weapons and
have sex
whenever we'd meet up we'd smoke weed
together he always had some
he owed money to his dealer and i owed
money to him
he said i could pay it back by working
for him i got offered free phones and
free weed and other stuff as well as
that
i said i wouldn't do it anymore once i'd
paid it back but then i got offered more
free weed so i just carried on
i'd seen other people get beaten up or
threatened or have
their houses smashed if they said no so
i couldn't
it got worse pretty quickly he'd get
people to sit outside my house to keep
tabs on me
unless it's sent you must wear a face
he told me that if i was out when i
wasn't supposed to be
he'd put our windows through
i was never given any tickets i was just
told to jump the trains
i went locally at first then to other
cities
i'd carry the weed and sometimes coke in
a bag
my boyfriend got me working for another
guy who asked if i wanted to make some
money by packing weapons
he was higher up than the other dealers
so i felt protected
i just did the drops jump in the trains
again
i was made to have sex with some of the
guys i was worried about what would
happen if i said no
because i saw others get assaulted for
not doing stuff
but it got to a point where i knew i was
in this really deep
i realized i needed help i didn't want
to be involved in the gang but was
worried about what would happen if i
said no
i knew it couldn't carry on a report by
the national youth agency shared
exclusively with sophie ridge on sunday
says that young people like alicia are
at risk of exploitation from county
lines gangs
more than ever the report also says the
typical victim is
changing more affluent more female many
youth workers have also reported victims
getting younger
i think we need much greater public
awareness of what's going on
sarah parker works for the local youth
charity who are now helping alicia
adjust to a new life the impact is
absolutely devastating
she says there are many more stories
like alicia's we have seen
social media being used very widely to
groom children primarily that's that's
why because
children have spent all that time online
and
and have been encouraged to education's
gone online you know their parents have
have known that
that kind of keeps them occupied it
stops them from getting bored
it means that they can remain in contact
with their friends but it also means
they can be in contact with
with other people but we've also seen
social media
um being used to advertise job
opportunities
for children to make quick money um so
actually some of the kind of the roles
in county lines exploitation have been
advertised
i mean take the example of alicia she is
in no way
um what you would consider to be a
traditional victim of county lines
exploitation
she's a girl to start with um she comes
from
[Music]
a settled loving and economically stable
home um and and yet she's been drawn
into this
this terrible situation that's had a
huge impact both on her
and on her family um so yeah i think
we're seeing there's kind of been a
much wider range of children have been
targeted and drawn in
youth workers and charities across the
country have told sky news they've seen
more girls in particular being exploited
by county lines gangs during the
pandemic
now politicians like the chair of the
parliamentary group on knife prime
are also worried if you're talking about
girls caught up in county lines they're
not part of a gang they are victims of
gangs
and unless we look at it from a gendered
approach we won't
address this issue and one of the key
things
that we also need to look at is the data
we're still we're still unclear about
how many young women and girls are
caught up in this
activity the police may say they've had
a great year in in terms of arrest
but it's not a great year when at the
end of this you're seeing
women and girls still being exploited
you're seeing women and girls being
violently raped by gang members
you're seeing women and girls probably
stash in some of these drugs
and weapons and their properties
endangering other family members
so that's not a great success linux
rogers a former gang member himself
now works with young people who need
help turning away from life in a gang
his phone hasn't stopped ringing during
lockdown
we talked to a lot of people we needed
to
get out there and help young people then
the families addressed these issues
there were some young people
that we worked with who were working
their shifts got reduced in covid
and so it had an impact on their
finances
and and they had some friends
some of whom were negative influences
and they were introduced to drugs you
know and they were showing them
oh you know you could have this you
could have that
and it was very tempting um
you know increased their business um
because
um people were struggling to cope with
mental health issues
and they used drugs to cope with
escapism and you know
i noticed quite a few young people that
we're new to it thousands of children
are exploited by county lines gangs
across the uk
each year luckily for alicia she got
help
but the road to recovery is a long one
i'm finally getting some help
i'm listening to people i'm trying to
get my life back but it's really hard
what's our peace on county lines there
well let's talk about that with our next
guest the shadow home secretary nick
thomas simmons thank you very much for
being on the program
thank you for listening across the
report that we just did too
um how concerned are you about the rise
in
children and young people being
exploited during the pandemic
it's a deep concern and just listening
then to alicia in that report
really did bring home to me firstly
the increasing number of county lines
has gone by
near 300 percent over the last decade
but also
during the pandemic as that report
brought out
it's clear that the profile of people
who have been drawn in are getting
younger
and more and more young women and girls
getting drawn in
as well now what we need to see it seems
to me are two major things
i think firstly we need to see strategic
leadership
on this issue at the home office i think
it was a grave error
to abolish the serious violence task
force which was announced to great
fanfare
because often county lines are
associated with other types of crime
including gang violence
but secondly we need to be doing all we
can
to give these young people who are
getting drawn into county lines
the opportunity to make a very different
life and we see that for example
in london where the mayor of london has
introduced a
rescue and recovery fund to actually
invest to try and ensure
that people get the help they need this
is an awful crime it's exploiting young
people and it really should be
a top priority now to try and do all we
can to deal with it
now staying on policy and crime you of
course are publishing labor's a plan to
tackle
violent crime and help support victims
what's the idea
well look firstly i think we have to
realize the scale
of the problem violent crime has gone up
in every single police force area of
england and wales over the last
decade in four out of five areas it
has doubled and there are now 200
violent crimes happening every hour this
is a chronic
failure frankly under this conservative
government
violent criminals have never had it so
good and we've got
to tackle that so what do we need to do
and what am i suggesting
today well we need more police
out there on the streets not behind
desks
we need to make sure that we change our
approach to preventative services not
see them decimated as we have
over the last decade we need tougher
sentences for example
for rape and we need in my view now to
have a
victim's law victims should be at the
heart of our criminal
justice system and that's why i think we
actually need to put that
into law so there's a victim's law that
puts victims first
you know i've listened to what you said
and i sort of read into
a bit of what you're proposing as well
and of course the rise in violent crime
is something that everyone will be very
concerned
by but i can't help thinking that some
of the ideas sound very good on paper
but actually things are a lot more
complicated than that i mean the first
thing you said for example is insuring
more police
on the beat rather than behind desks but
if violent crime cases have doubled
charging rates
have fallen down 22 in 2014 15 to 6.8
in 2019 20. it feels to me like the
problem is
actually convincing the crown
prosecution
service to take these cases forward it's
about building the case work i mean
that's often done from behind a desk
isn't it doesn't sound quite as
you know appealing as getting more
bobbies on the beat but that's a reality
isn't it
well no no it is a systemic failure and
the point that is made there about
charging rates is absolutely right as
well but that is
a failure right through the criminal
justice system from this government
which has
obviously cut the budget of the ministry
of justice by an extraordinary amount
since 2010 but my point is this you have
to have systemic change
right from the start so we we took it
took many years for the government to
admit
that falling police numbers were
actually related to the rise in violent
crime and that's why now we've got to
focus on
visible policing community policing
which has suffered so much
over the past 11 years so that that acts
both as a
lincoln the eyes and ears of the local
community
but also assisting in terms of detecting
crime
but you're absolutely right to say that
this goes right through
the system and that's why i've suggested
the other things that i have
around crime prevention preventing
people from becoming victims of crime in
the first place
but then looking at it right through the
system and that's why
putting victims first is so so important
and that's why i believe
we now need to have legal duties to
ensure that victims get the support they
need
from start to finish in the criminal
justice system that doesn't just mean at
the end of the trial by the way because
just because a trial has ended
doesn't end the trauma for the victim we
also need to see a system whereby
victims are
kept informed and have that information
support they need
post-trial as well talking about victims
you know the second
thing that you said you wanted to do was
tougher sentences for rape
the maximum sentence for rape is life
imprisonment and the problem
again is about getting those convictions
in the first place so in the year to
march 2020
1.4 of rape cases recorded by police
resulted in a suspect being charged
that's a real problem
tackling it isn't about getting more
bobbies on the beat it isn't about
you know easy wins on getting parliament
to vote through tougher sentences
it's the difficult painstaking work in
getting
those convictions in the first place
doesn't it
it absolutely is and i find this debate
so frustrating because
a support plan for rape survivors in
recent weeks in addition
to the measures that i've announced
today and you're absolutely right
because
99 of every 100 reported
rapes doesn't even reach legal
proceedings
let alone a conviction and what we need
to be putting in place
is that support for rape victims at the
very start
secondly we need to be fast tracking
rape and serious sexual violence cases
through the system so people are
waiting months and months in sometimes
some cases
years for justice but we also need and
we've argued this in recent weeks a
specific minister with responsibility
for this
with responsibility for rape and serious
sexual violence for precisely the reason
sophie that you've just said so that you
can drive change
right through the system and that's
absolutely what we require in addition
to raising that minimum sentence for
rate which is currently at five years
but
absolutely it is changed through the
system that we need and i'm so
frustrated
because i've asked for this for the last
five years and the situation is simply
getting worse okay i'm keen to
ask you about the protests that we've
seen this week outside at batley grammar
school
this is after a teacher showed an
offensive cartoon of the prophet
muhammed
the schools apologized suspended the
teacher who's now under police
protection should teachers be allowed to
show cartoon to the prophet muhammad
well look in in this particular case i
think we just need
to lower tensions firstly
the school has actually taken action as
you've mentioned
in relation to this which i think was
the right thing to do but what we've now
got to do
moving forward is absolutely to be
putting
children learners first lowering those
tensions now and
actually moving forward i think that is
what is absolutely
essential now because to continue
to to raise tensions in this situation
certainly isn't going to assist anybody
at least the
least alone those people who absolutely
should be coming first who are those who
are learning
at that school in battley but you think
suspending the teacher was the right
thing to do
look i i think the school has acted that
has now
obviously taken place that action has
happened i think what now needs to
happen as i say
is we need to lower the tension and we
need now
to actually move on putting the children
first we can't have either
any situations where teachers or others
are somehow intimidated trying to go
about their work that is something
that's not acceptable what we have to do
is to move on now and ensure that the
children have that learning particularly
at the moment when you consider
all the disruption there's been to young
people's education over the past 12
months that absolutely has to come first
okay and we have been talking about
scotland a lot on the program after alex
salmond
set up this new party in scotland
which is going to be contesting the list
seats in the election
um ken mccaskill said that's all about
trying to build a super majority for
independence
we've heard from douglas ross the leader
of the scottish conservatives who says
he wants to effectively build a super
majority for the union labor is saying
no though why not
why not well because labour is putting
forward
its own strong arguments at this
election i mean what i see are the
nationalists splitting
obsessed with the constitutional
question the
conservatives simply seem to want to
play politics with the union it's the
labour party in scotland
or andhra sawah who are making
absolutely clear
the focus now has to be on the recovery
from the corona virus i think quite
rightly that's what people
not just in scotland but people right
across the united kingdom
should expect of political parties we've
had this huge national crisis
with the coronavirus now is the point to
actually get that recovery
plan in place anasawa has spoken very
powerfully about that
whether it's around education and the
catch-up that's required whether it's
around our national health service
and the nhs in scotland and all the work
that needs to be done
on non-coronavirus cases our community
recovery
that's the case that we are putting
forward
to the people of scotland anas is making
that case very powerfully
and of course i will support him in any
way i can in doing that
i just quickly uncovered we also heard
from oliver dowd and of course the
culture secretary and we were discussing
the idea of this
traffic light system for foreign travel
and amber light for example meaning you
just have to quarantine for a short
period with enhanced testing
is that something the labour would
support
well look if that is put forward in due
course i'll of course look at it and
consider it in the light of the
circumstances of the time
but the priority at the moment is the
gaping hole in our defenses
at the border and closing that we have a
situation where we've got
vaccine rollout and great credit to
those of the front line doing that
and the sacrifices the british people
have made over the past 12 months
and yet we do not have that
comprehensive
hotel quarantining system in place at
our borders i think only about one
percent of arrivals at the moment
are actually being put into hotel
quarantine now that has to change i've
argued that for
weeks and weeks and the reason i argue
it is because
we do not want to see a variant of the
virus reaching our shores that threatens
the efficacy of our vaccines
we have to do everything we possibly can
to stop that
and that should be the priority at the
moment in the form of a hotel
quarantining system that's comprehensive
just finally
reports on the papers today that
annelise dodds could lose her position
as shadow chancellor
and be sacked in a reshuffle you a
little bit relieved you've been put up
for the morning round this morning
perhaps
saying or might be safe in your position
i don't take any notice of the gossip
and the speculation that appears in the
newspapers around this it's something
that
part of political life annalisa dodds
i've been working with over the past uh
12 months
is doing an excellent job and as a very
strong team
led by kierstarma we are the ones who
are putting forward the very clear
choice of this election
of a labour party that's on the side of
communities recovering from the
coronavirus
around the country in contrast to i'm
afraid a conservative party that just
wants to take this country back to the
past
a politician not interested in reshuffle
speculation that must be a first
nick thomas simmons thank you very much
for being on the program
now before we move on quick reminder do
check out the safety rage on sunday
podcast we record it straight after the
show and this week of course we're going
to be discussing the developments in
scotland
amongst other issues and you're going to
be able to listen to that from lunchtime
on the sky news app spotify apple
podcast wherever you
usually find your podcasts now this week
china
imposed sanctions on 10 uk organizations
and individuals for spreading what it
calls
lies and disinformation about human
rights abuses now the sanctions hit five
conservative mps
including the former minister mr ghani
who joins us now and
what happened well it's a curious state
of affairs sophie a number of us were
sanctioned and i think
that chinese communist parties thought
that they were intimidating us or were
going to stop us talking about
gross human rights abuses particularly
in xinjiang but it's been a complete
misstep by the chinese communist party
it's done a couple of things instead
it's actually made parliament come
together
and say we won't have democratically
elected officials intimidated anyway
it's also safe given us an opportunity
to talk about the one thing
the chinese communist party do not want
us to talk about which is the gross
human rights abuses against the uyghur
people and the fact that a genocide has
been called out
against china on the way that they are
treating the weaker people by many
countries around the world
you of course spoken out very strongly
about some of those human rights
abuses i just wonder if you feel that
the uk government has been tough enough
in its dealings with china
if you look at for example the
integrated defense review published a
couple of weeks ago
it calls for a positive trade and
investment relationship
with china you know given the treatment
of the uyghurs given the situation in
hong kong given the fact this is a
country that has sanctioned
british mps is that really good enough
well we must remember these sanctions
are in retaliation for the uk government
sanctioning chinese officials who have
been
implicated in the gross human rights
abuses so the uk government is
definitely in the right direction we
would ask many of us colleagues
will ask that the uk government goes
even further and sanctions even more
chinese officials who are involved in
the abuses in xinjiang
and what's also come about because of
the sanctions sophie
a greater discussion about where we
stand
in the new global order if the chinese
communist party is going to be using
both its
financial power through its belt and
road initiative and also using these
so-called sanctions to try and silence
individuals like myself i think these
sanctions are a turning point in how we
consider our long-term relationship
with china but not just us individually
just the uk but also working with our
partners countries like america for
example
i think this is a moment that i don't
expect the chinese communist party
wanted to come about
because of the sanctions but we now have
an opportunity to think about
are we going to assert our values and
how we're going to do that
now boris johnson hosted the mps who had
been sanctioned
yesterday in downing street couldn't
help but notice that tom tuggenheim
wasn't there the
chair of the foreign affairs select
committee who also was sanctioned
um he tweeted to say he wasn't invited
do you know what happened
the meeting was organized very quickly
at the last minute because the sanctions
came about over
overnight on thursday we were made aware
of them on friday and the meeting came
about very quickly
on on saturday but look all of us
colleagues
were sanctioned for doing what we've
been elected to do
which so was he invited do you know we
were all invited at very
very um last minute sophie but what's
what's critical here is that we met with
the prime minister and the prime
minister standing
side by side with us which i don't think
was the outcome the chinese communist
party thought they were going to achieve
with the sanctions i assume they thought
that we would be
marginalized by our party and that we
will then feel intimidated in talking
about the abuse of the uyghur
but that definitely is not what has
happened just feels a bit strange you
know
that he tweeted to say he wasn't invited
he wasn't there he's obviously one of
the most high profile
critics of china and the uyghurs you
know it'd be a pretty bad look obviously
for the prime minister to be speaking
at life with free speech but not
inviting tom tugan
perhaps because of things that he said
so for the best of your knowledge
that's not the case he was invited
people were invited at very last minutes
i mean another
parliamentary colleague was in
leicestershire wasn't able to get down
in time um but the story here sophie is
that
we are not going to be intimidated we're
continuing to speak about the abuse of
the weaker and we now have an even
closer relationship with the officials
in our government whether it's with the
prime minister or whether it's a foreign
secretary who are going to be even more
vocal because of the meeting that took
place yesterday
and the statements the foreign secretary
made so whatever outcome the chinese
communist party thought they were going
to achieve with sanctioning
um elected officials that definitely
hasn't happened and all we've been able
to do is talk about the abuse
of the uyghur and if i have a moment
sophie is talking about two million
people that are in prison camps
in xinjiang and it is an issue for us
because they are forced into labor
and those products eventually end up on
our shelves here in the uk
yeah a really important point to get
across and it's pretty clear from
speaking to you that these sanctions are
not going to
silence you if that is the aim and just
very finally while i have you
and we're talking about the road map out
of lockdown
the government asked parliament to
extend the emergency code restrictions
for another
six months earlier this week and you
abstained in that vote
um why did you abstain well we know that
the road map concludes towards the end
of june and
you know the government's doing a
fantastic job on that but there was a
particular
issue within the legislation which is
that the powers were to extend
up to october which is three months
beyond the road map and i just felt that
that was
unnecessary there is every opportunity
for parliamentarians to come back to the
house and for the executives to put
forward their position
and for that debate to take place we
know that the roadmap will will conclude
in a couple of months time of course the
government needs flexibility
but i just thought it was unnecessary
for for those rules and regulations
those powers that exist also in other
bits of legislation
to be in position for three months
beyond um the roadmap but look
um you know in in sussex we've had 1
million people vaccinated so i'm just
really pleased that the vaccination
program is going incredibly well
and we're getting towards the end of um
this covered
lockdown and we'll be out of it by the
end of june yeah you can meet up with
five other people outside from tomorrow
it will be incredible very exciting news
right garnier thank you very much for
being on the program today thank you
thank you
well that is it for the main show busy
one lots of different covers
topics covered on the show after the
break we're going to be going over all
of the main things we learned
getting some analysis with our political
correspondent rob powell that's on
sophie ridge the take
straight after this break so don't go
anywhere
[Music]
you